>>
Does India have the appetite and possibility
to become a superpower?
The answer is absolutely yes.
But we have a long challenges before even
we could consider ourself on
the path to becoming a superpower.
We need to address some very critical issue
in infrastructure, health
care, and education.
And unless these issues are addressed, I do
not think the opportunity
to become a superpower.
But once, if these issues are addressed, that
would create a domino
effect for a lot of people in India and that
would give us the ability
to compete on a global stage on many issues,
and thus enabling India to
become a new superpower.
Thanks.